[MUSIC PLAYING]
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
59 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good,
thanks, Francesc.
We are apart once again.
It's very sad.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yes, we
are very, very far apart.
Last episode, I made you
wake up really early.
This time you're
making me stay up late.
Well, it's, like, 9:30 PM.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, which is
about the time I'd normally
be in bed, so it's pretty late.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah, Mark
is lucky to be in San Francisco
where I'm enjoying
this ugly city.
No one has heard about it.
It's called Paris in France.
Yeah, you know.
MARK MANDEL: Oh yeah.
Paris is the worst.
I hate being in Paris.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And yeah, it's so weird.
It's, like, people
speak different--
I don't know.
I don't know if I like it.
But yeah, we have a
very cool episode today.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, we have
a return guest yet again.
Love it when our
guests come back.
Paul Newson is returning to
speak to us about his SRE
rotation once more.
He's now actually
finished it so he's
coming to talk to us about being
a Site Reliability Engineer.
Yeah.
And it is very interesting,
because even though he
has pretty much the
same messages as he
had at the beginning,
basically saying,
you know, I think that these
are the things that are the most
important, now
he's like, oh yeah,
those are definitely the things
that are the most important.
He's gone through battle and
came back with some lessons
that he's going
to share with us.
So very good interview,
very excited about it.
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
The fire has tempered the steel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Pretty epic.
I like it.
And then after that,
we're going to have
a question of the week
related to App Engine--
App Engine and services
that used to be called
modules, and which one is the
default one, and versions,
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
All right, well, that's great.
Well, before we
go we talk to Paul
and we talk about our
cool things of the week--
I particularly
like the first one.
It has to do with one of my
favorite things, Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yep.
MARK MANDEL: So it is
a open source project
by the name of Fission,
a serverless functions
as a service for Kubernetes.
So if you've become a fan
of, like, quote, unquote
"serverless
programming" or anything
of that sort of mantra,
this could be really cool
because it is an open source
implementation of being
able to run functions
on the cloud,
but on an open source
project like Kubernetes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is pretty cool.
I'm actually going to try it.
I saw that I think the
only languages that
are supported for it by now
our Python and JavaScript,
but I said "by now"
because I hope that that's
going to be changing soon.
But I will definitely
have a look at it
because it's a very
interesting thing of having,
like, basically, the same idea
of having cloud functions,
but it is completely open
source so you can run it
on your premises, or
you can write it on GKE
and you have full control of
whatever things they're doing.
So that's pretty great.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
the thing I'm kind
of excited by-- so you can
respond to HTTP requests, which
is fair enough--
standard HTTP stuff.
But the thing I
quite like is it will
respond to Kubernetes events.
So as different stuff
happens inside your cluster,
you could respond, like,
fire up different things
inside your cluster.
It could be really
interesting ways to do things
like custom autoscaling or
custom provisioning, something
that I'm playing with a lot.
So I think that's quite cool.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: That's
a very interesting thing.
And I've always the same
concern with everything
that was related to
functions as service,
which is how are people going
to manage their source codes?
I think that that's a
very interesting thing
that not many people
have thought about it,
and very excited about
what is going to happen.
Are we going to have
spaghetti functions?
Who knows.
MARK MANDEL: You know
what we should do?
We should reach out to
the people behind Fission,
see if we can get
them on the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
That's a good idea.
There you go.
MARK MANDEL: Well, if you're
listening, just reach out.
We would love to have you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, hello, friends.
And then we have the second
part, the second cool thing
of the week.
It's actually kind of fractal.
It's a bunch of things.
It's a series of
blog posts, which
are completely on-topic
with today's interview
because it's about CRE.
Which is not SRE,
it's CRE, which
is Customer Reliability
Engineering.
And basically, those
are the people that
are SREs for our customers.
And they go through,
as you were saying,
fire that temples the what?
I already forgot.
MARK MANDEL: Fire
tempers the steel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There you go.
So yeah, they go through the
fire that tempers the steel,
and then they write about it.
So there's a bunch
of blog posts.
I had not seen them before.
And some of the
blog posts I'm going
to be reading while
flying around the world.
They look very interesting,
and the cool thing
is that it is not, like,
theoretical things-- are
things that actually happen
and how to solve them.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
particularly, I
think if you listen
to this episode,
we talk a lot about
SLOs and SLAs, which
you'll hear about later.
And there's a whole blog post
about those particular topics
and why they're important.
So if you want to learn more
about those particular things,
you want a little light
reading, that's definitely
a place to go check out.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And I actually just
realized that we have one more
cool thing of the week, which
is actually incredibly cool.
And it's not in
the show notes yet,
but the SRE book is now free.
MARK MANDEL: Yes,
that is totally true.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So go read it.
It is totally awesome.
I have two copies of it--
one that I bought, another
one that I got for free,
and now maybe I will get
another one for free.
But it is definitely worth it.
There's so much stuff
to learn from it.
MARK MANDEL: Yes.
Yes, you should
definitely do that,
and we will definitely have a
link to that in the show notes.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
So I think it's now
time to go talk to Paul.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, our colleague.
And it's an honor, because he's
the first SRE advocate ever.
He coined the term.
And he said it was
coined in 2016.
So you know, it's been
a long time since then.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, SRE
advocate 2016, Paul Newson.
That's where it came from.
Cool, let's go to
talk to him, then.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's do that.
So very happy to welcome
our dear friend Paul Newson
back to the podcast
for the third time,
owning the record of number
of appearances in this podcast
other than for Mark and I. So
Paul Newson, how are you doing?
PAUL NEWSON: I'm
doing great today.
How are you guys?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Doing great.
Very happy to have you back.
I was looking at it--
in February 24, 2016,
so almost a year
ago, we had you for
storage with Paul Newson.
And then 14 times 2
plus 10, which is 38.
We had you to talk about
Site Reliability Engineering.
And that was almost
six months ago.
And you've been learning a
lot about Site Reliability
Engineering since then, so we
were very happy to have you
back to talk about that.
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah,
I think at the end
of the previous podcast,
I made a suggestion
that hey, maybe after I'm
done with my mission control
rotation, I can come back
and maybe share a few more
insights, hopefully know more
about what I'm talking about
than I did the first
time around when I'd only
been doing it for a few weeks.
MARK MANDEL: Before we get
sucked into that, I mean,
for people who don't
know who you are,
do you want to give us a
little spiel about you?
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah, sure.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
I do not believe
there's people that do not know
who Paul Newson is, but OK.
MARK MANDEL: I'm sure most
people know who he is.
Yeah.
PAUL NEWSON: Oh yeah.
Yeah, I'm that internet
famous, I'm sure.
No, I don't expect
anyone to know
who I am, unless, of
course, you listened
to the previous episode of
the podcast, and if you did,
that was months ago, so why
would you remember that far?
Back but I am Developer
Advocate at Google.
I work on the Cloud
Developer Relations team
with Mark and Francesc.
But for the past eight months, I
did a very interesting rotation
where I embedded myself with
one of our Site Reliability
Engineering teams, specifically
the Site Reliability
Engineering team that
looks after Compute Engine.
And the idea was
to hopefully learn
enough about Site
Reliability Engineering
that I could go out as
a developer advocate
and talk about it.
Because telling the story of
how we manage our services,
and by extension, if you're
using our cloud platform,
how we manage the infrastructure
that you're using,
is a very interesting
story to tell,
and it's something that I
hope I can share with people
and give them some
confidence that you want
to run your stuff on our stuff.
That was the idea
at the beginning.
And I would say
that I've certainly
learned a lot of things that
I want to tell people about.
And hopefully we can touch
on some of those today.
But what's interesting is that
the SRE culture that I just
embedded myself into
for eight months
has a lot of insights
that are useful to more
than just Google.
This isn't something that is
Google-specific or Google only.
There are other
people in our industry
who are doing great work that's
very similar to what we do here
at Google, and there
are very real lessons
that you can apply to
your services running
on our services from how
we do Site Reliability
Engineering at Google.
So now I'm very excited
to go out and share
some of those things with
the broader community.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
And so very quick
recap, as well,
for people who
unfortunately didn't
listen to the previous episode.
What is Site
Reliability Engineering?
What is an SRE?
PAUL NEWSON: So Site
Reliability Engineering
is what Google calls
the operations function.
And to once again quote Ben
Trainer, like I did last time,
it's what happens when you put
a software engineer in charge
of your operations function.
And so what you end up with
is a culture of automation
and a culture of using software
to make the operations problem
better or easier or faster.
And as I touched on
in the last episode,
there are some really
important insights to this,
because when you operate
at very high scale,
if you try and scale
the number of people
taking care of your stuff
with the amount of stuff
that you have, it
quickly becomes
an out-of-control problem.
So instead what
you do is you hire
people who are really
good at automating things.
And yes, you do some
manual work along the way,
but your primary job-- the
thing you spend more than half
of your time on--
is automating that toil,
as we call it, away.
So those are sort of the two
halves of Site Reliability
Engineering.
There's a certain amount of
keeping Google up, responding
to incidents, being on call,
and then the majority of the job
is building software to
make the services easier
to run so that as you
double your customers
and double again
and double again,
and you add more features
and add more features,
and you increase the surface
area of this product,
you don't also have to double
the size of your operations
teams again and again and
again, because that just
becomes impossible to do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So it's kind
of like that thing of go away
or I will replace you
with a simple shellscript,
but to yourself.
PAUL NEWSON: Yes, exactly.
You want to automate
yourself out
of a job as quickly
as possible so
that you can go on to something
newer and interesting.
A common characteristic of
many Site Reliability Engineers
at Google is they
get bored very easy.
So, you know, you do something
once, you do it twice,
and then you write a script.
It's a very common
thing in our industry.
It's not unique
to Google at all,
but we do try to live
up to that, sort of,
way of doing things.
Because for us, it's
not just a case of well,
I don't want to do
it a third time,
it's a case of by the time you
have to do it a third time,
you've got these other things
that are piling up, as well.
So you want to automate these
things as quickly as you can,
otherwise, pretty soon you won't
be able to keep up with it.
You just won't be able to
do it manually anymore.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
that is very interesting.
We covered that in the
previous episode, episode 38.
38, 34?
MARK MANDEL: 38.
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: 38.
PAUL NEWSON: I feel like
I'm repeating myself
for a lot of this.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: No, but
it is very interesting.
And I guess that if people
are interested on what
is the whole
philosophy behind SRE,
they should just go
listen to that episode.
MARK MANDEL: This
is SRE the sequel.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
this is SRE the SQL.
So I guess you've been an
SRE for a bunch of months--
six months, eight months.
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah,
it was eight months.
And I'm still wrapping
up a couple of projects
for the SRE team I was on.
So by the time I'm done,
it will have been nine,
10 months of SRE work.
I'm pretty happy with that.
It was a good body of work.
It was enough time for me
to really hopefully make
a positive impact on the
team that hosted me, and not
just suck knowledge
out of their heads.
But also to be able to
internalize it and really walk
in their shoes for
long enough to be
able to represent their
world view to the internet
out there today.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So when we first had
you on, you'd been on,
I think, for about a month.
Now, obviously, you've
been there for eight.
How did the end differ
from the beginning?
How do you feel
like your impression
has changed since that time
period of being an SRE?
PAUL NEWSON: So I
actually went back
and re-listened to the
previous podcast this morning
in the hopes that I
wouldn't repeat myself.
Well, that's exactly what I just
did because those thoughts were
in my head.
But hopefully they're still
interesting to this audience.
But I made some statements
at that time about,
you know, I'm just new
at this, and I'm mostly
repeating what I've heard.
And honestly, a
lot of the things
I said in that previous podcast,
they stand up today quite well.
So if you go back
and listen to that,
not only do I think they still
are quite applicable and quite
accurate, but I
received feedback
from some fairly
senior Google SREs
who listened to this podcast,
and they were quite positive.
They said, hey, you
really did a good job
of representing what we do.
And we find we are
often misunderstood,
not just in the
industry, but even
within Google, as what is the
difference between development
teams, SRE teams, and
what is traditionally
thought of as operations.
So however, I'd say the
big difference between what
I had experienced at that time
and what I've experienced now
is since then, I got trained up
enough so that I actually went
on call and carried the pager.
So I was the first responder
for a piece of Google Compute
Engine for several weeks since
I spoke to you guys last.
And that was a very
interesting experience.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I would
call that, like-- yeah, I
would panic, probably.
MARK MANDEL:
Interesting, terrifying.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Interesting is a nice
way of putting it.
PAUL NEWSON: Yeah, it's
an interesting experience.
And it can be terrifying.
I got to say, like,
the first time
that I saw my name listed on the
page that shows who's on-call,
that was a little bit surreal.
And to be fair, I've
been on call before.
I worked on the
Cloud Storage product
before I joined
Developer Relations.
I was on call for that
product at the time.
But I helped build it, so
I really felt like, well,
throw whatever you want at me.
I know how this thing works
from beginning to end.
I can probably troubleshoot
what's going on.
This was a very different
experience for me,
and is more typical
of the SRE experience,
where you are given something
that somebody else has built,
and yes, you become very
familiar with it over time,
but I can't possibly know
it as well as the people who
built it, right?
So I've gone from being on-call
for something that I built
to being on-call for
something I didn't.
And that was a little
bit terrifying.
But what was very reassuring
was you're not out there alone.
It's not like here's
the pager, good luck.
We'll see you in a week.
There's an entire team.
Yes, you are the
first responder,
but there is an entire
team there to back you up.
And mostly what you need to do
is apply good judgment on when
to escalate and when to bring
other people in, and also know
what are those paths to do that?
So I was primary
on-call when we had
what is called an incident,
which is something that's
significant enough that you need
to bring other people into it.
You can't just fix
it quickly yourself.
And so I had the
experience of going
through the entire incident
management process.
And it really
begins a lot earlier
that when you go on-call.
You do a lot of training,
you learn about your product,
you do projects in your project,
you shadow other people,
you are secondary, and then
eventually, you become primary,
and you are on point.
But when you declare
an incident at Google,
there is a tool that
we use to sort of track
the state and the
status, and show how
are you communicating about it.
Where do people go if they want
to participate in the response?
And at no point
during the incident
was I the one
fixing the problem.
It was all about
making sure that people
who could fix the
problem were on the case
and doing the right things.
And then when the
incident was mitigated
and service was back
at 100%, at that point,
you start a post-mortem.
And this is something I
talked just a little bit
about in the previous interview,
but I now know much more
deeply, having gone through it.
These post-mortems are
incredibly useful things.
Google has what we call a
blameless post-mortem culture.
So the idea behind
writing a post-mortem
is not to figure out
who made a mistake
and then to punish the guilty.
It's actually the
opposite of that.
You assume that--
we believe that--
the people who were involved
in the incident response,
the people who were
on call at the time,
are qualified to be there.
They've been trained
as well as we can.
They are well-meaning
and well-intentioned.
And when things
go wrong, it's not
because people should
have done better.
It's because the
environment around them--
the tools, the processes,
the monitoring,
the alerting-- these things
somehow could be better.
And if you want to avoid
this problem in the future,
you need to change these
tools, the processes,
or change the product so this
particular type of problem
can never occur again.
And that's what the post-mortem
is supposed to bring out.
And so you write
the post-mortem.
Everybody, you know, adds
their thoughts to it.
You file a bunch
of follow-up items
because a document
that nobody reads
and nobody acts on
is no good to anyone.
These things are
filed and tracked,
the same as any
other product issue.
And then at some
point, you have what
we call incident
review meeting, where
a group of people who work on
that product and the people who
are involved in the
particular incident
will get down and
get into a room
and review the post-mortem.
And this is also a very
interesting experience
because it does a
couple of things.
One, it helps improve
the post-mortem,
because you have people there
who weren't directly involved,
but who are very experienced
and bring a fresh perspective,
and they might think
of additional things
that you didn't think
that we can follow up on
to make the product better.
But the second thing it
does is it socializes
this particular incident
among the responders--
the people who might
respond, have to respond
to things in the future.
And it builds this
culture around we
learn from these problems
we have in the past
to make things better.
And these review meetings are
an important part of that.
So I think the question was
originally what's different now
from the beginning?
And I'd say the most
significant difference
between what I
knew then and what
I know now comes from
living through being on-call
and handling
incidents at Google.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So that sounds
like it's very interesting.
And for those that do
not have the privilege
of being able to do what you did
and becoming an SRE for almost
a year, I guess that there's
many resources out there.
I think that one of my
favorite ones is the SRE book.
I guess you would
recommend that book.
PAUL NEWSON: I would
highly recommend that book.
In fact, when I went
through my orientation,
we had some senior SREs
who'd been at the company
doing the SRE role for years
come and have lunch with us.
And one of them said,
yeah, everybody who's
an SRE should read this book.
I learned things from this book.
This is somebody who's
been doing it at Google.
Because the way this book
was put together was it
was sort of crowdsourced
within the SRE organization.
So what you really have
when you have that book
is a collection of
authoritative essays
written by the person at
Google who knows that subject
the best, right?
So, you know, for
example, there's
a chapter on post-mortems,
which I just discussed,
and a chapter on
incident response,
which I just discussed.
And they were written
probably by different people,
and probably by the people
who were best positioned
to really write the
authoritative treatment
of that subject.
Well, nobody at
Google is going to be
as knowledgeable about all
of the subjects covered
by that book as the individual
authors of each chapter.
So longtime SREs at Google get
benefit from reading that book.
So yes, I do highly,
highly recommend it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So for
those that are lazy--
too lazy to read
that book, like me--
I actually have read the book
and I think it's amazing.
But for those that do not have
the time to read the book,
if you were to highlight
one specific theme
or one concept that is very,
very important for an SRE--
something that you may have
discovered during this year--
what could that be?
PAUL NEWSON: So I think
the most surprising--
and I won't say it
surprised me because it
was a concept I was really
aware of from my previous work
on cloud storage.
But the importance
of having really
well-thought-out
service-level objectives.
The surprise isn't
that that's important.
The surprise to
me was how central
that is to everything
you need to do
to think about reliability.
MARK MANDEL: So what is a
service-level objective?
PAUL NEWSON: So let
me back up a second.
A service-level indicator
is something you
can measure about your service.
So for example, let's just
take a simple request response
sort of HTTP service.
A very simple
service-level indicator
is what percentage of my
responses are 500 class?
So error rate.
And, you know, that's
a very relevant metric
that you should probably be
tracking and have on a graph,
and maybe even alert on.
But what turns a
service-level indicator
into a service-level objective
is sitting down and asking
yourself, well, for
this indicator, what
is the threshold?
Like what is our goal?
What are we trying
to reach here?
So for example, if we're
talking about error rate,
maybe you want to be three 9's.
So you're going to give
yourself a goal of 999 times out
of 1,000 you are going to
serve a non-500 response.
Maybe that's the
goal of your service,
and maybe that's appropriate
for your service,
but you have to think about
it from the customer's
point of view.
Like what is that transaction?
What is that HTTP request
you've been given?
Is your service something
where all these HTTP requests
are idempotent and
can be easily repeated
with exponential backoff?
Three 9's is probably very
sufficient for something
like that, because what's
the client going to do?
What's the user going to do?
Well, the client's
software is probably
going to retry
automatically for them,
and the user will never
notice that a 500 was served.
So what transforms
an SLI into an SLO
is this user insight that
you have to bring and say,
for this indicator, what
is an acceptable threshold
beyond which we shouldn't go?
Now, a lot of people
would call that an SLA,
a Service-Level Agreement.
And at Google, we
try very hard to be
clear about what is an SLI,
Service-Level Indicator?
It's just something we measure.
There's a graph
somewhere that you
can go look at that tracks
whatever that metric is.
A service-level
objective is an SLI
with a threshold of
some kind applied
to it-- some sort of goal.
An SLA is a legal contract
between two companies that
are doing business together.
And they kind of look
like SLOs sometimes,
but really, the SLA
is the contract.
You can have lots of
services that have
SLOs with no SLA whatsoever.
Like I collaborated with
Philippe, our colleague,
on a post about GitHub
reliability a few months back.
And GitHub is a service.
If you're just using their
free service, they have no SLA.
It wouldn't make sense to have
a service level agreement.
You're not paying them
any money, how can
they give you a credit?
What are they going to do,
like, write you a check
because they gave you a 500?
No, it that doesn't make sense.
But I'm quite sure that
internally at GitHub, they
have objectives for how many
errors they want to serve.
They have SLOs even though they
don't have a public-facing SLA.
So the SLO is the thing that
drives your decision-making
around almost everything
you do with your service.
And I'd say that is what I
found the most surprising.
That is the most
valuable insight
that I've come away
with from this rotation.
You know, let's say,
for example, you're
trying to figure out how many
regions do I need to run in?
And so you can analyze
your architectures
and say, well, if I run in
multiple zones in one region,
I can expect this
sort of reliability.
If I run in multiple regions,
I can expect more reliability
because I'm now more redundant
across more geographies.
Should I do it?
It's more expensive.
It's more engineering work.
If your SLO demands that you
need that redundancy, then yes,
you should do it.
If your SLO doesn't demand
that you need that redundancy,
then you shouldn't do it because
you're just wasting money.
If your SLO is
well-chosen, your customers
will not notice the
difference between meeting
it and exceeding it greatly.
There is no extra value to
exceeding your SLO greatly
if you've chosen it well.
An example would be
that most people connect
to internet services through
networks that only provide
three or four 9's to them.
So while you could provide
five 9's for your website,
that additional reliability
is pretty much imperceptible
to your customers.
You are spending a lot
of effort and money
providing a higher level of
reliability that provides
no value to your customers.
Now, there are, of
course, services where
this doesn't apply, right?
Anything that is life
safety-critical, anything
where failing a request has
an actual cost each time.
They may require a
different calculus
on how to think about your SLO.
But that's something that no
one can decide for you, right?
You understanding your users
and having empathy for them
and thinking about
your product--
only you can choose your
SLO, but once you do,
that can help guide
architectural decisions,
operational decisions,
deployment decisions,
technology decisions,
and so on and so on.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
I think we've had
very interesting discussions
about having SLOs drive, like,
feature development in terms
of how much work should
we put in on this thing because
changes are essentially risk.
PAUL NEWSON: Right.
Yeah, so that's a
very, very good point.
I think I made the point
in the previous interview
that if you want to have a
service that is 100% reliable,
that's easy--
never change anything.
I exaggerate, of course.
Even then, depending
on your service,
you still wouldn't have 100%.
But the point is
every change you
make to your service
carries some risk with it.
But how do you decide if
that risk is worth it?
You know, this is a
fantastic feature.
We absolutely have to ship it.
We have to ship it tomorrow.
How do you think about the
risk of shipping that feature?
Well, have you met
your SLO this month?
Do you have some
error budget leftover?
We talk about SLO
and error budget.
They're sort of two
sides of the same coin.
If you have, say, a
99.9% SLO, that means
you have a 0.1% error budget.
If you haven't served
any errors this month,
yeah, it's risky to
push this new version,
but if something bad
happens, well, you'll just
eat into your error budget.
That's what it's there for.
On the other hand, if you've
had problems this month
and you've already
exhausted your error budget,
give your users a break
and wait until you've
had some periods
of high reliability
and you've replenished your
error budget before you
push that change.
It also reflects on
things like well,
how do you push your changes?
One of the great
recipes for how to have
a wonderful global
extended outage
is to push a change
everywhere all at once
and have no rollback plan.
That's a great recipe for
an extended global outage
to your service.
Instead, if you do your
rollouts progressively,
so you push it a
little bit over here,
wait, monitor, see if
anything goes wrong,
push a little bit
more, wait, monitor,
see if anything goes
wrong, and so on and so on,
you could do this over
a period of hours,
over a period of days,
over a period of weeks,
even, depending on what
SLO are you trying to make.
What is the right pace
to push out your changes?
That depends on your SLO.
All of these questions--
like, I can't tell you
whether minutes, days, or
weeks is the right pace
for your rollout.
You can only answer that based
on what SLO you're going for,
and that will guide
you in the decision
to what kind of rollout and what
pace of rollout you need to do.
And then again, do
I absolutely need
to have a rollback
plan for this?
Well, the now SRE that
lives on my shoulder says,
of course you need
a rollback plan.
That's the most important
thing you can have at rollout.
But looking at it objectively,
if you have very low SLO
and you can basically
re-push your entire service
in a couple of hours, and a
couple-of-hour outage is well
within your SLO, then
I guess you could
push without a rollback plan.
But one of the best ways
to improve your reliability
is not to never break anything,
but to make sure you can always
fix it quickly, right?
Because outages that
are measured in minutes
are not as painful
as outages that
are measured in hours
or, heaven forbid, days.
So having great, well-tested
rollback plans and rollback
tools such that yeah, sure, I'm
pushing this thing and I pushed
it here and then I waited 24
hours and then I pushed it here
again, I waited
another 24 hours,
and then I saw
something was wrong--
well, now I can
roll back, and not
that many people were
affected to begin with.
And we were able to
mitigate it really quickly.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, we're definitely
coming up on time.
We could talk about
this for hours on end.
Before we finish up, is there
anything we haven't covered,
or maybe, like what
you're next up to.
What are you doing next
after this rotation?
PAUL NEWSON: So let's see.
If you like what I have
to say about this topic
and you didn't find a half
an hour of me, you know,
rambling on about
it to be enough,
I'm hoping to put
together a talk for NEXT.
So come to the conference,
come see my talk.
And I also hope to basically
take this message on the road
and get out to other events
and talk about these things.
The other thing that
I'm hoping to do--
I had a goal, and I
think I spoke about it
in the first podcast, to almost
write a diary of my mission
control rotation.
I thought it would
be really cool
if people could
sort of play along
with me as I went through.
Turns out being an SRE can
be rather all-consuming,
so my series of blog posts
turned into two blog posts.
But I have another
one on the way,
and I'm hoping to continue to do
more because these insights are
pretty timeless.
So keep an eye on the
Google Cloud Platform blog,
and hopefully you'll
see some things from me
there on this topic.
And the other thing
I'm hoping to do
is I now feel like I have a
very good understanding of how
Google approaches this.
One of my hopes for going
out into the community
and going to these conferences
and talking about this is not
just to stand there
and say, hey, this
is how Google does it.
You should do it this way, too.
But I want to learn a
lot more about well,
how do people who
aren't Google do this?
Like, there's a
broader community
out there doing things that they
call Ops or DevOps or sometimes
SRE, and I want
to understand what
does this look like
if you're not Google?
Because I believe that'll
be really important
for us to guide our customers
to do the right things.
Like, some of the things that
we do at the scale we operate at
may not apply.
Some of them may
to our customers.
The other thing
I'll do is just give
a quick mention of this program
we have now called Customer
Reliability Engineering.
This is essentially SREs who
work directly with customers.
It's a very small program.
It's just getting started.
We wrote a blog post on it.
I won't say any more
about it because I'm not
an expert on it, but I
just want to make you aware
that it exists.
You should go read
the blog post.
And if you're curious
about it, there's
probably some contacts in
there you can follow up with.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Great.
Well, looking forward to
seeing your talk at Cloud NEXT.
Just in case people
are wondering,
that will be in San
Francisco March 8 to 10.
So see you there,
and thank you again
for taking the time to tell
us about your experience.
And looking forward to reading
all of those blog posts
that I hope you're going
to be writing soon.
PAUL NEWSON: Thanks, guys.
MARK MANDEL: Thanks again to
our always reliable colleague
Paul Newson for joining us.
We had a splendid conversation
about being an SRE
and all the things involved.
Super, super interesting stuff.
And, like, yeah, that
SRE book is free so,
like, there is no excuse
not to go read it.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
definitely worth a read.
And it's actually
very well-written.
Basically, instead of a really
big book with just one message,
it's a bunch of little stories
of how we do things at Google.
So it's easy to read.
You can read any of
the sections that you
care about, so
definitely worth reading,
especially for the price,
which is free right now.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, so let's get stuck
into the question of the week.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: So we're
talking about App Engine.
So if you're using App Engine--
and so App Engine allows you
to have multiple versions
of an app up in the
cloud and running, which
is really, really useful.
But if I'm using
an App Engine and I
want to see which version
of my service that I have up
and running in the cloud,
which one's default, which
is the one that everyone is
seeing when they access, like,
my usual URL, Francesc,
can you help me out?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
So there's a couple things
about this question.
So first, I think the
important thing is
to understand that inside of a
single App Engine application,
you can have actually
many services,
which is what we
used to call modules.
Which are the same thing.
We just changed the
name, basically.
And every single
one of those modules
can be written in a
completely different language.
So it can be cool.
You can have some
Python and then some Go
and something written in Java.
MARK MANDEL: We do that
on the podcast, actually.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
We do, absolutely,
because we have one module
in Go and one model which
is static content, so
they're independent.
And then inside of each
one of those modules,
you can have many versions.
And that is very
useful, especially
when you're doing AB testing
or just testing, basically.
If you want to have
something tested
in prod, which is not a
great idea, but we all do it.
So you're going to
deploy it and then
make sure it actually
works before you send
all your customers
to that and new web
page or that new service.
So before, we actually had that
concept of the default version,
meaning that if you did not
specify which version you
were going to target,
then you could
target that default version.
And that thing
actually went away.
There's no such thing
as a default version.
Instead what we have is
we have traffic splitting,
which means that you could
do something like actual AB
testing, saying,
you know, I'm going
to have 50% of the traffic
going to version A,
then 25% going to version B, and
another 25% going to version C.
MARK MANDEL: So I would also,
like, smoke test new features.
Like, 10% of the traffic gets
a new feature, test it out,
make sure it works,
and then if it does,
I can just increase the
traffic that it receives.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
You can do AB testing, you
can do, like, experiments,
and see, like, oh,
only 1% of the people
hitting the web page are going
to see this new feature to see
if they like it or not.
That means, basically, that
you cannot check which one is
the default version
of a service.
Instead what you can
do is you can list
all the versions in a service.
And when you do that, which
there's a REST API called
apps.service/get.
So you do a REST
API there, and you
get a list of all the versions
running in the service,
and which is the traffic
split that they got.
So the [INAUDIBLE]
of default would
be 1, which is 100%
of the traffic.
But you could get, like,
as we're saying, 0.5, 0.25,
or whatever else you want.
MARK MANDEL: So it's not
quite as simple as the default
[INAUDIBLE] option
used to be, but is
much more flexible in terms
of what you can actually do.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Basically, it is.
You can still implement
that default version, saying
100% traffic goes there,
but you can do much more,
which is actually very good.
MARK MANDEL: That sounds good.
I like it.
Excellent.
All right, Francesc, I know
you're still out and about
and having fun in Europe.
Where are you going to be
over the next little while?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So I'm
going to go to Brussels
next for [INAUDIBLE]
where I'm going to be
joining two of our coworkers.
I'm going to be joining
[INAUDIBLE], which
we interviewed a long time ago
about big data and BigQuery.
And also, I will meet with
Ray, which we interviewed
last week about Java.
So we'll all get the three of
us there, so if you're around,
come say hi.
And after that,
I'll be coming back
to San Francisco for just
a little bit, basically,
do laundry, and then
go to GopherCon India.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I'm
very excited about India.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: How about you?
MARK MANDEL: Still doing
same old, same old.
Very busy getting things ready.
GDC is turning out to be a huge
game developer conference here
in San Francisco.
We're sponsoring
multiple events.
It looks like we're going to
have a booth, which is great.
A little last-minute,
but fun, fun, fun.
So I'll be running
things at the booth,
so I'll be sure to tell everyone
what's going on there shortly.
Sponsored session.
I'm doing a lightning
talk at the Developer Day.
Lots going on, so I'm
getting that all ready.
And then yeah, Cloud NEXT
comes the week after,
which will be fun,
fun, fun, as well.
I know you and I
are both speaking.
It's going to be
delightful time.
And I believe we also have
space for the podcast,
so if you want to come
and hang out and maybe
get a recording in that we
may or may not use later,
definitely swing past and
say hello at the podcast.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Absolutely.
MARK MANDEL: Well, Francesc,
it was a pleasure and a delight
to talk to you once again.
Missing you here
in San Francisco,
but it will be nice to
have you back here soon.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Same here.
A pleasure.
And I'll be back to San
Francisco very, very soon.
And so see you soon, and
thanks everyone for listening,
and talk to you all next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]